okay so I need a little fashion secret
we're gonna start - everybody give me a
quick fashion secret yes I know that's
an attractive but we're a sweat pad it's
soaked it all off sweat pad under your
arms he'll have something to blot your
face with detector oil off yes
I'm sweating like underwear it goes a
really long way
I need the sweat pad right now I'm
sweating I'm sweating I'm sweating all
right who have you seen so far that has
inspired you and who have you seen Oh
Ava Duvernay always she's so divine tell
you I freaked out cuz I was walking in
by Oh Davis said I love you I love how
gorgeous does she look stunning in black
and white just stunning I love this all
you guys got you have all the favorite
dilutive yes you are but there's
somebody you'll see that you'll be like
oh oh we have cause always always but
that's not what you lead with you don't
leave with negativity you focus on the
positive start with the nice and then
work your way down yeah well I'm gonna
I'm gonna be nice you guys do look
fantastic for real thank you and good
luck and what's in your clutch very weak
Oh powder yeah
and valet ticket and money they ticket
don't lose that by the way you only said
bodies off he's moving this weekend into
it how do I know
really I'm still selfish never done
actually
[Music]